okay i said i had four categories from
soft off classes reciprocals squares my
last one is the trickiest one you've
heard of simultaneous equations right
sanitizer credence it's where you've got
two or more equations and you know they
meant to operate together in the same
universe well just the same way you can
have simultaneous inequalities okay I've
got three things joined it but not oh
oops I need a work
ok here's the first thing and again we
have seen this in induction proofs
appear before you just weren't that
familiar with it if you've got two
inequalities right so again simultaneous
inequalities these exist in the same
universe but there's some common feature
between them right then you can string
them together interchange so if you have
these two things together what they
imply is that a is bigger than B is
bigger than C but in turn what that
implies is that a is bigger see ya so I
can draw a conclusion about these
opposite empty because they relate
together by this single quantity of you
okay so i can string them together in
the same way everything that I did
overhear you see how I can combine you
know this inequality and is constant
this inequality and these constants okay
i can combine inequalities with each
other like these guys right so first
let's think about additional don't worry
about this okay so the first thing i
want you to know is the inequalities are
facing the same direction that's
important to me if the inequalities are
facing in the same direction but it's
just same way with simultaneous
equations you know how sometimes you
solve by substitution but other times
you solved by elimination by adding or
subtracting acquaintance through another
right well you can add or subtract
either qualities from each other to so
long as the inequalities are going the
same way okay so if these two true
together what they apply is this you see
how I've added the left-hand sides are
both inequalities and the right-hand
sides of both inequalities now it you
pause from of it I theologically we can
see this is true the way I've written it
here it's like I've got two big things
yeah then together I have two small
things yeah they're together well it
makes it two big things will be bigger
than the two small things but how would
you prove it how to prove it like that's
the intuition that tell ya looks
reasonable but what of what's on the
board because look you know all of these
tools and property
disposal what could you use to prove
this result what do you think okay so i
can take advantage of some of this like
if this is an addition thing then i
would think that my addition properties
are go you so to me right okay here
comes my trip so write this underneath
is my proof of this years old because
it's kind of like the first one where
it's like yeah I think so but how I
really really know right i want to start
for the first inequality is bigger than
be right all right that means that and
take away v is going to be friends if
you agree with that yeah but in the same
way that i can get this from here right
i also get an equality about this now
this is really useful because whenever
you can say things are positive or the
definite ability or you're definitely
negative you could reason with them
together so now I've got hey this number
whatever it is they take would be it's
positive and this stuff I see tech ID is
also positive so these two numbers
together they have to be positive right
does that make sense when you combine
them that's what's going on here yes so
I could say therefore a takeaway be I'll
see take away d that's got employee do
you see how I extended the logic just a
teeny bit right I consider both those
numbers both having to positive and now
it's just some very trivial
rearrangement here right why don't I got
here got a plus C take away the policy
just factorizing out that so i could add
the whole thing and then there is the
result I was trying to prove today okay
yeah it's unfortunate I just just run
out of space so I'm just going to get
rid of this I've got one more property
to show you and then I want to tell you
about how you can use those properties
yeah for this one could your
you had stayed to both sides so you like
taking advantage of the addition
property of constants you just add yeah
my seat yes yep yep you can do that that
takes advantage of this and this
together yeah that's absolutely all
right now I said we can combine by
addition you can also combine by
multiplication so this is still under
simultaneous inequalities so if what I'm
doing is I'm multiplying together in the
same way as when i was looking at
Constance you have to sort of worried
about whether things are positive or
negative so just to keep things simple
I'm just going to stay in positive land
because that's where things are easiest
to see so if I've got those two pairs of
inequalities and be together CMD
together but I know everything is
positive so this okay I want you to
think if we were to combine these things
by multiplication and really remember
like I'm actually just thinking about
the a and the B not worried about this I
just want to have it in the back of my
mind same thing with here if you
multiply these inequalities together
there's the left hand side there's the
right hand side what would you expect to
be the case the inequalities should be
preserved right it should be preserved
that's kinda like a specialized version
of this right because this is also
multiply this just by itself yeah so
this is a special moment how would you
prove it like we prove this here can I
give you 20 30 seconds so we could it
yourself before I actually to show you
the logic is not that different it
doesn't take too many lines it uses only
the tools that I just showed you this
morning have a thing don't you puta once
both sides by our love is greater than B
I'm times both sides by CBS positive
okay so I'm gonna go with this right
multiply both sides by C because I know
things about see using my chain of
inequalities he sees one of the positive
numbers of
so therefore i can multiply it through
my ends that's good okay I'm gonna file
that away what would I do next okay go
with this guy right say well I also know
that to be true i'm gonna multiply by a
different positive number that i know
about namely hold on pause yo check it
see I've got I've got an ACP on it do
you think you're okay I've got an AC
here tick that's what I want on the
right-hand side i'm supposed to get
biddy biddy this damn right so maybe you
sit every other way before the chooser
I'll get smoked my both sides by would
be by the way i should say as well as a
biddable as it faster loose whenever you
do this right you should invoke the
reason why you can so here it's because
C is positive and here it's because
being was right like you multiplied by
something so the inequality is preserved
for a particular reason namely because
you know something and this came up in
induction all the time it's like
sometimes you have to multiply through
by like if you had to prove that
something was bigger than some multiple
of five or something like that it's a
you had to say oh yeah well i multiplied
by this or that and it's only because
it's positive that I know everything's
still fine and now I've got this and
this what am I going to do with these
yeah I'm going to combine them to string
them together to chain right so let us
say there for acs be do this bc is
bigger than B D which means i can get
that kind of little as required okay